now we woke up this morning thinking
that the nomination would not advance to
this committee because Kentucky Senator
Rand Paul was going to vote with the
Democrats and that wasn't going to be
enough to get him out well there was a
change in that and then we thought maybe
he would get out of committee with
what's called a favorable recommendation
but then one Republican Senator is
absent senator Isakson is in Georgia
attending a funeral so now they're
deadlocked in 10 10 throwing this all up
but the unexpected bit of news happened
right before this business meeting with
an unexpected tweet having received
assurances from President Trump and
director Pompeo that he agrees with the
president on these important issues I
have decided to support his nomination
to be our next Secretary of State he
joins Democratic senators Heidi Heitkamp
Joe Donnelly and Joe Manchin in
supporting Pompey's nomination likely
enough to confirm him the president
tweeted this morning quote hard to
believe obstructionists may vote against
Mike Pompeo for Secretary of State the
Dems will not approve hundreds of good
people including the ambassador to
Germany they are maxing out the time on
approval process for all never happened
before need more Republicans a majority
of Democrats continue their pointless
obstruction to score cheap political
points with their base as a willful
attempt to undermine American diplomacy
Democrats claim they oppose Pompeo
because they say he'll fail to check the
president's worst instincts
I believe our nation's top diplomat
unless before fright and more critically
his past sentiments do not reflect our
nation's values and are not acceptable
for our nation's top diplomat I believe
the American people deserve better
Republicans say Pompeo has the trust of
the President and note the Senate
confirmed him as CIA director by a 66 32
margin as a national security focused
nominee they say Pompeo deserves
confirmation just as the Senate easily
confirmed secretaries of State for
presidents Barack Obama George W Bush
and their predecessors Republicans say
they're pushing to confirm Pompeo in the
coming days NATO hosts a meeting later
this week for foreign ministers Pompeo
says he wants to be there officials will
likely discuss the Iran nuclear
agreement at that summit president
Trump's deadline on whether to withdraw
from the Iran deal is less than three
weeks away
then of course here the ongoing
discussions are trying to establish that
meeting between President Trump and the
dictator from north korea kim jeong-hoon
that's something that Pompeo has been
intimately involved in traveling there
during the holiday over Easter weekend
Republicans and Pompeyo say they want to
be able to do that as a confirmed
Secretary of State leading that type of
diplomacy Brett it's just to be clear so
right now they're trying to figure out
how to get this thing to the floor once
and if it gets out of committee to the
floor by a voice vote or whatever
mechanism corker chooses the Chairman
then they won't have a problem because
of these Democrats who are going to vote
for Pompeyo
that's right they have three key
Democrats three Democrats in total now
who have said they will vote for Pompeo
then they also have Kentucky Senator
Rand Paul on top so they feel as though
they've got enough they just have to get
him there and there's some procedural
issues right now in doing so all
contained within this committee in the
meeting that's happening right behind us
folks walking in right behind you will
let you do some work we'll get an update
later in the show thanks rich